Joey hunt very good morning to you
thanks so much for talking to us here on
Sky news this morning so Britain faces
its biggest hit to living standards on
record wiping out eight years of
improvements the economy is already in
recession and now people are facing a
huge rise in the tax burden you've been
in power for 12 years it's a pretty
bleak Legacy from the conservatives
isn't it
well what we have is a very challenging
International situation the dropping
growth in Germany for example is even
higher than here countries all over the
world are dealing with the inflation
shot caused by the Ukraine crisis and
what we have to do as a government is to
say what is the big thing that we can do
to help families to help businesses the
most and what people are worried about
is the rise in the cost of living that
Weekly shop going up their mortgage
rates going up their energy Bills going
up and this is a plan which when you cut
through the difficult decisions that I
announced yesterday it brings inflation
right down you start to see growth going
right up and you start to see our
economy getting back onto an even Keel
and that's the most important thing as a
conservative I know sometimes you have
to take difficult decisions but if in
the end that means more stability for
families and we're protecting the NHS
and schools as you said then we know
we're doing the right thing for the long
term and that's what we do in these
kinds situations would you say you say
that it's a challenging International
situation you're blaming Global factors
and undoubtedly the pandemic and the war
in Ukraine have had an impact but don't
the conservatives need to take some
responsibility as well I mean a lot of
what you're doing is about undoing the
mess that the mini budget made and also
taking steps to try to convince the
markets that you're trustworthy
well we reverse those measures in the
miniature budget in three weeks so I
think we acted very quickly we've been
completely open yes there were some
mistakes but when you look at America
that's increased taxes by 800 billion
dollars you look at uh Germany and
France that are now saying they're going
to reduce their borrowing and introduce
much stricter rules you look at what
Putin is doing in Ukraine this is an
international situation coming straight
after a once in a lifetime pandemic so
these are very serious issues sorry to
interrupt Jeremy Hunt but we have the
lowest growth in the G7 why is that
well that's not true we actually have
the highest growth in the G7 this year
and if you look at the last 12 years
we've actually had the third highest
growth in the G7 despite a lot of global
turbulence now over the next two years
it is going to be challenging but I
think people want a government that is
taking difficult decisions has a plan
that will bring down inflation stop
those big rises in the the cost of
energy bills in the weekly shop and at
the same time it's taking measures to
help people get through this difficult
period the support for energy bills will
mean that the average house will have
500 pounds less to pay in their energy
bills we've increased the national
living wage which will mean an extra
sixteen hundred pounds in the pay
packets of people who work full-time and
indeed protecting the triple lot for
pensioners so we're doing absolutely
everything we can to help people whilst
tackling this this very very challenging
International situation
but you're part of the same government
that said we were going to see the
biggest tax cuts in 50 years a 45
billion pounds worth just eight weeks
ago now you're announcing huge tax Rises
and spending cuts as well worth a total
of 55 billion pounds what's the public
supposed to make of this total reversal
in Direction in just a short space of
time what does it do to the conservative
party's credibility
well we've been honest with people that
there were some mistakes made but we're
also saying there are much bigger issues
to solve than what happened in the mini
budget we've got a big challenge because
of the costs of covid the costs of the
war in Ukraine and what we announced
yesterday was a long-term plan to see us
through to the other side and I think
people want a government that is
prepared to take difficult decisions to
write the economy to protect jobs
yesterday the office for Budget
responsibility said the measures I
announced will save 70 000 jobs they'll
reduce the severity of the recession by
about a third so that is a government
that is doing everything it can to help
families get through what is a very very
challenging period
will you say help families through a
challenging period but disposable income
is going to fall by more than seven
percent over the next two years that's
the biggest fall on record we're all
going to be a lot worse off aren't we
that's what happens when you have high
inflation and that's what happens when
Putin is able to Blackmail us and
countries all over the world by forcing
a big rise in international gas prices
and that's why one of the things we
announced yesterday was a new nuclear
power plant the first state-backed
nuclear power plant for 30 years to try
and stop people like Putin being able to
do that blackmail which is so damaging
to our living standards I think it's
important Anna to recognize as a country
we've had bigger challenges before
and we've always thrived and prospered
because people have been able to or been
willing to take tough difficult
decisions when they're called for
because people know in their hearts
there are big big issues that we have to
resolve and they want a government
that's prepared to take those decisions
people will also ask how they're going
to pay their bills I mean we're facing
the worst two years of modern history
for household incomes millions are going
to be dragged into higher tax bans
council tax is likely to go up energy
bills up again in the spring and they're
already
eye-wateringly high the resolution
Foundation says the typical annual tax
bill Will Rise by 1700 pounds how are
people going to afford it
well that's why we announced a lot of
things yesterday let me tell you some of
the things that we announced that will
help people first of all the cap on
energy bills at 3 000 pounds will save
the average house 500 pounds uh the
increase in the state pension by a
record 10.1 percent uh will increase the
average pensioners income by 870 pounds
then you've got the increase in the
National living wage which we talked
about up to sixteen hundred pounds then
we're doing one-off payments to people
on benefits of 900 pounds one-off
payments to pensioners of 300 pounds on
our payments to people on with
disabilities to of 150 pounds and then
you've got the reversal of the Health
and Social care Levy which is again
another nearly 400 pounds so you know
put those together and for the most
vulnerable people there are thousands
and thousands of pounds of help that
we're offering but we're doing more than
that we're saying what is the long-term
solution to these cost of living
pressures it's to bring down inflation
and this is a plan that sees inflation
fall markedly in the second half of next
year and that in the end is going to be
the thing that deals with people's the
root cause of people's worries and
that's what we've tried to do today
one of the things you mentioned there
and that was honoring the triple lock
seeing pensions rise with inflation is
it fair though that wealthy retirees
should enjoy that rise in their income
when public sector workers can't
well I think the truth is first of all
pensioners have retired they don't have
the ability to work more or work longer
hours in the way that uh people of
working age do but I think it's wrong to
say that only the poorest pensioners are
feeling the squeeze at the moment I
think this is something that's affecting
everyone and I think it's right having
made that promise to pensioners in our
Manifesto that we would have this triple
lock I think this is exactly the kind of
tough time that people want it to kick
in and so that's why I think it's the
right thing to do but when a lot of
people say you are protecting pensioners
but it's workers that are really being
clobbered aren't they given the tax
Rises that are being imposed on them
does it pay to work under your plans
well we've just increased the national
living wage to 10 pounds 42 that's
nearly 10 increase and that's precisely
to make sure we do reward people for
working and support people who are on
Lower pay so I think we're very aware of
those challenges we're not pretending
that this isn't going to be a difficult
time for everyone but what we have is a
plan we're protecting the NHS and
schools as we get through a difficult
period And when we get to the other side
you can see inflation coming right down
growth going right up unemployment
coming down all the things that you know
their economic statistics but they
actually affect ordinary families up and
down the country they affect how much we
pay for the things we buy the effect the
security of our jobs and that's why our
first responsibility has to be to take
the difficult decisions that sort out
the root problems the economy is facing
the tax Rises you've announced are
astonishing as a share of GDP that
they're at their highest level since the
second world war and there are many in
your own party that are deeply
uncomfortable about that about putting
up taxes when we're in recession they
say it's not very conservative
well the office of budget
responsibilities say yesterday that what
we're doing is actually making the
recession shallower it's saving jobs
um but what I would say to my
conservative colleagues is you know
there is nothing conservative about
spending money that you haven't got
there is nothing conservative about not
tackling inflation there's nothing
conservative about ducking difficult
decisions that put the economy on track
and we've done all of those things and
that's why this is a very conservative
package to make sure that we sort out
the economy which is one of the most
important things that people expect from
us as a party but they might say back to
you household incomes Falling by seven
percent in the next 18 months
essentially the run-up to the next
general election taxation as a share of
GDP at its highest level since the war
unemployment is going to be rising house
prices are going to be rising why would
you vote conservative at the next
election
and I'm gonna have to make this the last
answer I'm afraid because I've got to do
some other interviews but let me answer
that very directly people vote
conservative because they know we will
take the tough and difficult decisions
in the long-term interests of the
country that's what we are doing today
none of this is easy but it's the right
thing to do and if we're going to bring
down the cost of people's shopping bills
make people's jobs more secure look
after the economy then people know
that's what they get with the
conservative party at the same time as
that we're making sure that the NHS has
the support it needs our schools have
the support they need to get them
through a very difficult period and
that's why I think it's a balanced
package that everyone will feel able to
support thank you very much okay Jeremy
Hunt thank you we'll let you go and do
those other interviews thanks very much
indeed